so let's say he just has his number and  Izzy just can't figure out so a you're  ruining your biggest pay-per-view star  um hands down  so then uh Robert Whittaker or Robert  Whittaker's background is he was going  to be on the Australian national team  for wrestling so he can wrestle so if  anyone can rest at a high level I  experience fact and we know this from  earlier in his fights and he also gets  hit from time to time even at the High  Caliber uh striking level that he's at  but again go you go through those top  seven or eight guys all Alex pairs are  underdogging every single one of those  fights it's very short-sighted very  short side